Sufism is a difficult topic to Define in
short terms it is often referred to as
Islamic mysticism and while I do believe
that this can be a good place to start
it is of course a simplified and
sometimes even misleading way to talk
about this tradition this is for various
reasons only one of which is the fact
that it often lumps together various
different quote-unquote mystical
movements in the early history of Islam
indeed Andalucia or al-andalus was a
hotbed for this stuff in the Middle Ages
producing some of the greatest Mystics
in history but while this tradition and
these Mystics would eventually become
assimilated as a part of the wider
category of Sufism later on in the
earlier centuries it was not that simple
in fact this mystical tradition was in
fact a parallel tradition to the more
classical Sufism of the East the Islamic
East and actually had some really unique
and fascinating features of its own so
let's explore the origins of Islamic
mysticism slash kind of Sufism in the
lands of Andalusia
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
which is the southern parts of the
Iberian Peninsula was one of the
cultural centers of the Islamic world
and the world generally ruled by various
dynasties and Empires like the Umayyads
the al-muravids and the al-mahads it was
a place of a lot of activity on a number
of fronts in the great cities like
Cordoba and Seville scholarship
flourished and philosophers like even to
fail IBN rushed and even hasm among
others could produce their many
influential works and in terms of what
we call mysticism the same was true
we've talked at length previously about
some of the great sufis and Mystics who
came from Andalusia people
likeyan and others most of whom would
have a massive impact on the world of
Sufism and that's precisely the point
the word Sufism because indeed there
were parallel mystical Traditions that
developed in different parts of the
Islamic world not all of which can
necessarily be called Sufism without at
least further nuancing they were all
interconnected in many ways of course
but still when we talk about Western
Sufism represented by people like given
Arabi we often talk about how it's
distinct from Sufism further east
quote unquote Western Sufism tends to be
more speculative and more metaphysically
interested while Eastern Sufism is more
focused on psychology and the internal
spiritual wayfaring of the individual
Mystic and there's a reason for this
namely that there was a unique mystical
tradition that had developed in
alandalus that was distinct from the
Sufism of the East
indeed while later Muslim Sufi writers
would write about earlier Mystics of the
West as sufis in order to sort of
strengthen the sense that they all
belong to the same tradition this wasn't
always the case
in earlier times before figures like IBN
Arabi or IBN that somehow represented
both Traditions Sufism or sufis was a
term primarily associated with the
mystics of the central Islamic lands
primarily in and around Bhagavad or
modern Iraq tasauwolf which is the
Arabic term that we often translated as
Sufism was the tradition associated with
Mystic slack Junaid in Baghdad and
written about in the early Sufi works
like bushari's epistle the kitabaluma by
abunasra saraj and
this was a tradition concerned with
ethics and renunciant practices that
would help the Mystic travel on the
spiritual path through different
stations or macombs in order to reach
intimacy and Union with God and these
sufis had a particular terminology and
vocabulary that they became associated
with Concepts and terms like madifa
which means a kind of Gnostic intuitive
knowledge or mystical knowledge terms
like fanaa which is Annihilation or
Extinction in God this vocabulary in
these terms were very much associated
with the sufis right in Baghdad and in
the surrounding areas which had a
distinct kind of flavor at the same time
there were other mystical developments
further east in what is the Iran or
Persia in places like nishapur for
example the malamati movement people
like Abu yazida bistami these were not
necessarily considered sufis in the
early period from the time that these
early works of Sufism was written the
Eastern Sufism of course had an
influence on the west as well and by by
West I mean places like Western North
Africa the Maghrib as well as al-andalus
or Andalucia some of the great Sufi
Works spread and were read in Andalusia
and people who traveled to the East and
studied under sufis would of course
bring that knowledge back with them
which led to the gradual development of
a renunciation or renunciate tradition
in this region too
but at around the same time in other
words in the earliest periods of the
Islamic civilization they also developed
a parallel mystical tradition here in
the west one that took influence both
from the Quran and Hadith but also from
the philosophy of neoplatonism and the
speculation of groups like The Safa the
origins of this movement and of
mysticism in Andalusia in general is
often traced to the fascinating 9th to
10th Century Mystic philosopher IBN
masara his full name was Muhammad IBN
Abdullah al-jabili and he was born in
the city of Cordoba around the year 883.
having studied these standard religious
sciences and the Maliki School of
Islamic law ibiz Masada eventually
decided to travel Eastward he spent some
time in Cairo on in modern Tunisia where
he deepened his studies of Maliki law
and then he made his way to Mecca the
holiest city in Islam it is thought that
he encountered the sufis here and might
have studied under the eminent Mystic
Abu Saeed IBN al-arabi some Scholars
also suggest that he might have
encountered the Safa or Brethren of
Purity during his travels whose Epistles
might have influenced his neoplatonic
philosophical bands after his travels
and Explorations in the East IBN masara
eventually made his way back to
alantalus and Cordoba where he started
teaching and became famous as an ascetic
and mystical guide
a group of students later referred to by
Eben hasm as the masariya gathered
around him and it is said that IBN
Masada and his followers would Retreat
to the mountains surrounding Cordoba
where they spent most of their time in
religious and spiritual practice
it is for this reason that he's also
called al-jabali which can roughly be
translated to something like the
mountain dweller because he spent most
of his time up in the mountains outside
of the city already during his life it
was Masada and the masarians became
controversial among the ruling Elites
and many of the Malika jurists in the
region he was often accused of holding
unconventional ideas such as for example
teaching that it was possible for people
to attain prophecy which is most likely
a simplification or misrepresentation as
well as other supposed theological
positions what everyone agreed on was
that IBN Masada had a vast knowledge in
various fields and he was known for
speaking very eloquently and for having
a sharp mind as well as for his rigorous
aesthetic lifestyle he passed away in
the year 931 in his Mountain Retreats
outside of Cordoba but he had left
behind not only a group of disciples but
also a collection of writings the two
primary ones that have survived are the
kitabhawas the book of the properties of
letters and the result
the epistle on contemplation
and the latter work is especially
important for understanding his mystical
philosophical ideas because at the
center of IBN masada's thought is the
concept of etibar meaning contemplation
the word is connected to the term ibrah
which means crossing over from this
world to the other world
Masada describes how we can cross over
from the mundane world to the Divine one
we can Ascend to a Divine experience
through the practice of contemplation of
it this can be done through ascending
levels of contemplation in a very
neoplatonic way where one contemplates
and meditates on nature itself the
beauty of the world around us
the world is after all often described
as the cosmic Quran as a sacred
scripture that can be read by those with
eyes to see properly IBN Masada writes
quotes then God great and glorious made
all that he created heaven and earth to
be signs indicating him expressing his
lordship and his beautiful attributes
the world in its entirety is therefore a
book whose letters are his speech those
who seek to behold read them by the
light of true thinking according to
their perception and the scope of their
contemplation while the eyes of their
hearts are turned around the Manifest
and hidden Marvels
starting with contemplation of nature we
then Ascend in Rising levels of
contemplation until we reach the Divine
itself quote the world then with all its
creatures and science is a ladder by
which those who contemplate Ascend to
the great science of God on high
heu climbs must climb from the lower to
the higher they climb by means of the
intellects who ascend from their lowly
station to the point where they reach
the highest signs described by the
prophets
like climbing a ladder we start from the
physical World of Nature and Ascend in a
very near platonic way through the
planetary spheres than to the soul and
then the intellect until we reach
contemplation of God as the source of
all things within ourselves quote
thereupon you will find your lord and
Creator you will meet him in yourself
and you will see him with your inner
vision
at this point the Wayfarer will realize
and confirm the truths that the prophets
brought to see for themselves the truth
of the Divine the world and of
Revelation
these ideas became very influential in
the region and we can see clear traces
of them in the later Mystics like IBN
Arabi and IBN sabahin but shortly after
the death of the masara his ideas became
a point of controversy many caliphs and
Malika jurists in the region saw them as
heretical they were staunchly opposed to
his ideas they saw him as a kind of
heretic and so they even had his
writings burned despite this the
movements survived for centuries among
Mystics who were inspired by his ideas
because of the focus on ektibar this
group of Mystics in the lineage of IBN
masara came to be called the al-mu
otabirun the contemplators and was a
mystical tradition that developed in
parallel with the regular renuncian
tradition in the region and with
quanticoat Sufism in the east
even centuries later in the 12th century
we see significant figures and Mystics
clearly influenced by IBN masara thus
being part of the matabirun scholars
today often talk about the so-called
School of Almeria because it seems that
the masarian teachings and the
al-motaberun were especially prominent
in that coastal region in southern Spain
indeed in this very eventful 12th
century the motabiru unba represented by
fascinating figures like IBN Arif and
ibadjan who would have a massive
influence on the greatest Mastery even
Arabi especially
at this point you can probably already
start to see the direct connections here
and connect some of the dots between
these different figures and traditions
right a more prolific writer though and
arguably the most influential of the
motabirun at this time was IBN badajan
he was a great Mystic and Scholar from
the city of Seville known then in Arabic
as ishpilia
he was not only clearly educated in the
basics of the religion including things
like Theology and Islamic law but also
deeply involved in mysticism
he was aware of the teachings of the
so-called sufis but clearly consider
them a parallel tradition a different
tradition from his own in some way and
more so represented the masadian
teachings of the mataberun at the same
time it's also clear that his spiritual
practices included things like vikr a
meditation technique where one repeats
God's names or the proclamation of faith
and a spiritual Retreat one shuts
oneself off from the rest of the world
for a period of time to focus on
meditation and prayer both of which are
practices strongly associated with
Sufism in particular
so as you can see the relationship
between these terms and concepts are
pretty complicated but ibnbarajan was
also something of a philosopher even
though he would never use that term
himself
he studied deeply topics like geometry
arithmetic as well as other examples of
what was called at the time the science
of the Ancients
such as mathematics astronomy medicine
Alchemy and logic
indeed ibnbara John seems to have
criticized many of his contemporary
Mystics and renunciants in Seville for
there in his opinion excessive
asceticism and anti-intellectualism
sought to find a balance between
mystical unveiling and intellectual
Pursuits although at the same time he
was also highly critical of the
philosophers the mysticism that he
practiced aside from the more Sufi
related practices like zikr was one more
strongly connected to the motabirun and
even masada's ideas of contemplation
to live this life to the fullest
ibnbarajan eventually moved from the
city to the countryside just west of
Seville here he lived the life of a
farmer basically while also being a
respected spiritual teacher to a large
group of disciples he moved to the
countryside in order to be closer to
Nature where he could practice a tibar
by meditating on nature and witnessing
the Divine traces and the truth that was
manifested in it just like little masara
even barajan believed that one could
Ascend to the Divine through this
gradual contemplation of God's science
and traces his revelation
God reveals himself through what he
creates and he does so in different
modes all of the world is a single Unity
where there is a connection between the
different modes of Revelation a
correspondence between the different
kinds of qurans
creation itself the universe as a whole
is a revelation where God shows himself
whatever John refers to as the cosmic
Quran and qurani in contrast to the
written Quran Al-Quran al-tadwini which
is the book of the Quran as we know it
the sacred scripture of Islam revealed
to Muhammad
these two qurans correspond to each
other they both contain the entirety of
Creation in some way as even badajan
himself says quote everything in the
world is mentioned and alluded to in the
Quran and vice versa
and thirdly there is the human being
itself the constitution of the human
self and soul which also contains the
whole of Revelation it is the microcosm
to the macrocosm of the universe and so
it's the third Quran
is primarily concerned with the practice
of etibar contemplating God through his
science and traces the way that God
reveals himself through the three modes
of Revelation nature the written Quran
and the human self all these three are
to be studied and meditated upon to
reach the Divine just like how IBN
masara described the ascent on the
ladder to God
what is so interesting about ibnbarajan
aside from just that his ideas are
interesting in themselves is also that
we see in his ideas many many precursors
to the ideas of later great figures like
given Arabi as you can see the ideas of
someone like Ivan barajan and his
predecessors like Eva masara have clear
metaphysical and cosmological aspects
they try to map out at least to some
degree the suprasensible realities and
talks about how God creates the universe
as we know it this it has a lot of this
cosmology and these metaphysics which
are not present to the same degree in
the tradition that we call Sufism at
least in the early centuries and in this
metaphysical scheme he introduces some
fascinating ideas that probably
influence the great Mystics that
followed for example one of these
Central features of his cosmology is the
concept of the universal servants
this is the first thing that God creates
a kind of intermediary between God and
creation where everything is contained
in a single Unity before it is refracted
into the actual world of Multiplicity it
is neither God nor creation but
simultaneously both God and Creation in
some way this is obviously similar and
probably related to the new platonic
idea of the news or intellect in some
ways and even more significantly it
strongly reminds us of IBN arabi's ideas
of insanal camel the perfect man as well
as the reality of realities
furthermore even barajan talks about
something he calls the reality upon
which the heavens and the Earth are
created which is a name for the totality
of God's presence and creation all of
creation that which is other than God
massive Allah or the traces and signs of
God determined by his names and
attributes
so just like even Arabi later the world
is the manifestation of God's beautiful
names and attributes and the sum total
of those traces and presences is this
reality which he refers to
quote the reality upon which the heavens
and the Earth are created is to the
existing things like a point is to a
line it begins with it and is connected
through it and ends with it
this also we find a very similar Concept
in IBN Arabi and he even basically uses
this very phrase himself although he
shortens it to the reality upon which
creation is created
there are other doctrines such as
imbarajan's discussion of methali
imaginal existence that definitely seems
to be a precursor to even arabi's ideas
of the Islam and hayal the imaginal
realm and both IBN Masada and
ibnbarajan's interest in the powers and
significance of the Arabic letters as
building blocks of the universe is
inherited by the great Sheikh as well
commonly known as the science of letters
in short there are numerous ways in
which we can see how Mystics of the
motabiron had a major influence of the
theoretical metaphysics of the great
13th century sufis like IBN Arabi and
that's what's so fascinating about this
time period that we see the Confluence
of different mystical traditions we have
seen that al-andalus had developed a
unique and particular kind of mysticism
associated with the thought of IBN
masara and the taberon and represented
later on by people like
as well as a local renancia tradition
focused on self-inquiry and ethical
principles such as Charity and taking
care of the less fortunate this Valencia
tradition is partly a sort of homegrown
movement but also of course influenced
by writings and ideas of the sufis
further east which after all had made
its way to places like Al andalus
particularly writings like those by Almo
hasabi which Focus very much on
self-inquiry right self-inquiring about
the state of the Soul which was a a very
prominent aspect of this pronunciate
tradition in Seville and other places in
Spain but it's in the late 12th century
that we also see the emergence of a
proper self-conscious western or magrabi
Sufism this development is primarily
associated with the figure Abu madyan
who was also originally from the
Andalusian city of Seville but spent
most of his career in the Maghrib in
cities like fairs in Morocco by this
time Sufi works from the East like
alakazali's
and the risala of el cushery had reached
the Maghrib and Abu madyan studied these
Works under teachers like IBN heads in
Fez eventually he became a great Sufi
Master himself who gathered many
followers across Western with Africa
before he died in the city of tillemsan
Algeria in 1198 he had basically brought
Sufism to the West while also infusing
it with particular local features and
traditions a true Western Sufism was
thus born and Abu madyan is one of the
most revered and important Mystics in
history it was in his footsteps that
figures like about Hassan shadily
followed shortly thereafter and started
the shadowy Sufi order which became
dominant in the region ever since then
lastly we might even be able to consider
another movement that was emerging in
the so-called Wadi recruit the code
Valley in the region of murthia in
Western Andalusia here another mystical
development was taking place with ideas
that were much more radically monistic
and was represented by figures like
Abdullah
and would be primarily inherited later
on by IBN sabahin and al-shustari so as
you can see once we get to the 13th
century there is a whole lot of activity
going on the local mystical tradition of
the al-motabiron the renuncian tradition
centered in Seville and the later
emergence of a self-conscious Sufism
proper in the region through figures
like abomadyan and argued even the
monistic adjacent ideas in the record
Valley if that can be considered a
movement of its own
and this is the environment in which the
great figures of that age grew up IBN
Arabi IBN Ashish
they lived in a place and time where all
of these mystical movements and
tendencies intermingled and that is what
is so significant about them what
someone like IBN Arabi did was to take
all of that and in some way harmonize
them to bring them together we see clear
influences in the binary's writings from
the ideas of masara and IBN but also the
renouncian practices of IBN majahid and
the Sufism of abomadyan he and many of
his contemporaries represented all of
these Tendencies simultaneously now it
should be remembered as always that the
lines between these Traditions aren't
clear I don't mean to paint a picture
where all of these are separate schools
completely independent of each other
because that is far from the truth it is
a lot messier than that we can still get
an idea of the different kinds of ideas
and practices that were in dialogue at
the time
when IBN Arabi left for the east in the
early years of the 13th century he was
taking all of this with him in a way he
and his contemporaries were the
culmination of centuries of developments
in the region which they brought
together and took with him to the east
where their ideas would become very
influential eventually these unique
ideas and teachings associated with the
Islamic West became assimilated into and
sometimes formed core aspects of the
broader category of Sufism for the rest
of History usually when we talk about
people like IBN Arabi or even sabahin we
call them sufis and arguably this isn't
entirely wrong they definitely
represented Sufism in some ways even if
we Define that term more narrowly they
Incorporated that aspect of Islamic
spirituality as part of their teachings
that cannot cannot be denied but they
also represented other mystical
Traditions once they were strongly
related of course but still
indeed when we read the works by Eben
Arabi or a shoe study for example they
usually don't refer to themselves as
sufis but rather with words like
verifiers or realizers whereas arifun
knowers sufis to them was a particular
group of Mystics that they didn't always
identify with personally even if they
saw them as part of the same larger
tradition in some way it's a complicated
Topic in many ways and maybe only
relevant if you are really interested in
the semantics and things of that sort
when it comes to these topics but it is
true that from the time not too long
after these figures
all of this
Sufism of the the East the malamati
tradition the all these mysticisms of
the West it all became referred to Under
the Umbrella of Sufism a way of talking
about this that still is in use today
even Arabi was a Sufi even barajan was a
Sufi even if Masada was a Sufi and while
this isn't entirely wrong they certainly
belong to an interconnected mystical
sphere and and an environment in the
larger Islamic world at the time it's
also true that things were a bit more
complicated than that in the early
centuries we can arguably still talk
about Sufism in the broad sense of
encompassing all of this if we want to
we should also simultaneously be
conscious of the diversity and
complexity of andalucian and magrebi
forms of mysticism and this is also an
explanation why these Sufism of figures
like
so quote-unquote philosophical compare
compared to a lot of the earlier Sufism
in the East because they not only
inherited those renuncian practices and
the vocabulary of the Soul's journey to
God but also the much more
cosmologically and metaphysically
oriented ideas of the mod tabiron and
found ways to harmonize both in a
beautiful and impressive way this is one
of those topics that I've studied a lot
and so for that reason getting so much
information and Nuance
together in a relatively short form can
be pretty difficult but I hope this has
been an interesting introduction to the
origins and development of mysticism and
Sufism in the Islamic West in places
like Andalucia and the Margaret and
through this discussion we have also
hopefully been able to see how the
famous doctrines of people are given
Arabi developed in this region which
makes us better able to fully appreciate
the massive achievements of the Great
Western Mystics of the 13th century
thank you as always to all of my patrons
who support this channel if anyone else
wants to become a patron it really is
the best way to support this channel I
will leave links to that in the
description and in the pinned comment
look forward to more content on Sufism
and related topics in future videos very
soon and I will see you next time
[Music]
thank you